[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Freitag alles zum Trainerwechsel
bei den Bayern hat gleich Norbert
Lehmann ein schöner
Sorge vor dem mega-streik am Montag
Spediteure fordern LKW diesen Sonntag
ausnahmsweise auf die Straße zu lassen
ein Land zwischen Russland und Europa in
Georgien verspricht Außenministerin
baerbock die Annäherung an die EU zu
unterstützen
und Trainer Beben beim FC Bayern der
Rekordmeister trennt sich von Julian
nagelsmann
[Musik]
überzogen und verantwortungslos oder ein
legitimes Mittel im Tarifstreit um mehr
Einkommen an dem bundesweiten waren
Streik scheiden sich die Geister klar
ist Millionen müssen sich am Montag auf
einen Zusammenbruch des öffentlichen
Verkehrs einstellen und entsprechend um
planen um buchen oder zu Hause bleiben
Profiteure sind die Anbieter von
Mietwagen und Fernbussen Christoph
kleiner Vorgeschmack auf den großen
Streik die Schleusen am
Nord-Ostsee-Kanal sind schon mal zu zu
dem Wasserstraßen dann noch die Züge die
Flugzeuge und und und das muss so sein
rechtfertigt sich die Gewerkschaft Verdi
Arbeitskampf der keine Wirkung erzielt
ist ein zahnloser Arbeitskampf immerhin
stellvertretend für die Arbeitgeber
deutet die Innenministerin an noch so
ein Montag droht wohl kaum ich bin
sicher dass wir nächste Woche eine gute
Einigung für die wertvolle Arbeit
unserer Bediensteten im öffentlichen
Dienst finden werden
ändert nichts am absehbaren Chaos zum
Wochenstart keine Fernzüge kaum
Regionalverkehr auch in den Flughäfen
allenfalls Notbetrieb und dazu die bange
Frage was geht da noch auf den
Autobahnen Sperrungen etwa am Elbtunnel
wird es schon mal nicht geben verspricht
die Autobahngesellschaft doch allein die
durch Überlastung drohenden Staus können
zum Problem für die Logistikbranche
werden sie schläft vor lass die Laster
ausnahmsweise am Sonntag fahren denn
Lebensmittel da geht es um
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdaten da geht es um
Arzneimittel und ist natürlich ganz
schwierig diese Strukturen ja zu planen
wenn wir nicht wissen was uns genau am
Montag erwartet besondere Maßnahmen
findet auch der Verkehrsminister okay
wir unterstützen das und haben die
Länder auch geraten dass man keine
Kontrollen durchführen sollte am Sonntag
erst Indizien dass es wegen des Streiks
eng auf den Straßen wird massiv
gestiegene Anfragen bei den
fernbusanbietern die planen schon mit
zusätzlichen Bussen auch Mietwagen gehen
weg wie nichts trotz Aufschlägen und bis
zu 90% und dann gibt's ja noch die die
Reisen schon gebucht haben für sie gilt
Kunden deren Bahnreise ausfällt können
entweder ihr Ticket bei einer späteren
Fahrt flexibel nutzen und zwar noch bis
zum 4 april oder den Kaufpreis
zurückverlangen und auch die Flugtickets
kann man umbuchen oder gegen Geld
zurückgeben
bei gebuchten Hotels kommt auf die
jeweiligen Bedingungen an so oder so
könnte es am Montag für sehr viele
Menschen ziemlich kompliziert werden
fragen wir unsere Rechtsexpertin Sarah
Tacke Sarah wenn Arbeitnehmer wegen des
Streiks einfach keine Möglichkeit haben
zu ihrem Job zu kommen dürfen sie dann
zu Hause bleiben
Arbeitnehmer müssen auch an einem
streittag pünktlich bei der Arbeit
erscheinen denn ein Arbeitnehmer trägt
immer das sogenannte wegerisiko heißt
konkret als Arbeitnehmer muss ich alles
mir Zumutbare unternehmen um es
rechtzeitig zur Arbeit zu schaffen also
eine Fahrgemeinschaft bilden aufs
Fahrrad umsteigen unter Umständen sogar
ein Taxi nehmen Ausnahmen wie oder
Alternativen wie Homeoffice Überstunden
abbauen Urlaub beantragen geht eben nur
nach Rücksprache mit dem Chef eine
Ausnahme gibt's für die Eltern kleiner
Kinder wenn auch die Kita bestreikt wird
dann können Sie unter Umständen das
Recht haben die Kinder zu Hause zu
betreuen da kommt aber auf den
jeweiligen Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitsvertrag an Stichwort Kinder und
Jugendliche müssen die in die Schule
auch wenn kein Bus fährt
ganz klar ja auch Schüler müssen am
Montag in der Schule pünktlich sein aber
erste Bundesländer wie Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg haben bereits gesagt
wenn die Kinder nicht rechtzeitig
schaffen dann gibt es da Ausnahmen aber
da geht Eltern und Schüler sind
verpflichtet ihrer Schule Bescheid zu
geben das heißt grundsätzlich sollte man
ob nun mit Chef oder Schule im Gespräch
bleiben damit man gut durch diesen
Streik Montag kommt das ist
grundsätzlich gut im Gespräch zu bleiben
vielen Dank Sarah kacke
wenn Sie wissen wollen was bei ihnen am
Montag zu erwarten ist alle
Informationen zum Streik noch mal zum
Nachlesen in unserer ZDF heute App und
auf heute.de
jetzt zum EU-Gipfel in Brüssel dort gab
es heute weiter Gezerre um die deutschen
Sonderwünsche beim geplanten aus für
verbrennermotoren in Neuwagen unstrittig
ist dass es 2035 für Benziner und Diesel
kommen wird
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing aber
pocht darauf das Verbrenner die
ausschließlich mit efuels laufen weiter
zugelassen werden gesucht wird ein
Kompromiss seit Tagen gehen Briefe und
Vorschläge zwischen EU-Kommission und
dem deutschen Verkehrsminister hin und
her und fröler in Brüssel ist jetzt ein
Kompromiss gefunden und der Streit vom
Tisch
nein ich glaube leider nicht ich glaube
dass die Fronten weiter ziemlich
verhärtet sind und dass es sehr sehr
schwierig ist ein Kompromiss zu finden
die Bundesregierung vor allem die FDP
pocht eben wie gesagt auf eine Garantie
für Verbrenner und die Kommission sagt
das können wir nicht machen und das will
sie auch nicht machen weil dann muss sie
noch mal das komplette Gesetzespaket
aufschnüren und dann kämmen viele andere
mit Sonderwünschen was die Kommission
jetzt als Kompromissvorschlag vorschlägt
ist eine sogenannte Ehrenerklärung dass
die Kommission sagt ja wir sehen für
Verbrenner auch eine Zukunft aber diese
Ehrenerklärung hätte eben keine
rechtliche Bindung und nun muss man
sehen ob das für die Bundesregierung und
für die FDP reicht ob eben das Wort das
Ehrenwort der Kommission gut genug ist
danke schön für diese Informationen aus
Brüssel
auch der Ukraine Krieg war Thema beim
Gipfel die EU beschloss der Ukraine
innerhalb eines Jahres 1 Millionen
Schuss Artilleriemunition zu liefern vor
allem im Osten des Landes gehen die
Kämpfe unvermindert weiter wie in Kopien
die Stadt ist wegen ihrer Lage
strategisch wichtig Russland greift dort
wieder massiv an und es besteht die
Gefahr dass die russische Armee kopians
zum zweiten Mal erobert eine Brühl war
dort an der Front
es ist die Fahrt durch eine Geisterstadt
wir sind den kopiansk 30.000 Menschen
haben hier einmal gelebt jetzt sind die
meisten geflohen weil das Leben hier
viel zu gefährlich ist
im September wurde Kopie Ernst befreit
nach einem halben Jahr russischer
Besatzung jetzt liegt die Stadt wieder
unter heftigem Beschuss und die Anwohner
sind aufgefordert Kopierens zu verlassen
wieder einmal
die Behörden bereiten die Evakuierung
vor es gibt Notfallpläne aber im Bus
nach haarkif sind viele Plätze frei noch
wird keiner zur Umsiedlung gezwungen
es ist gefährlich alle die bleiben
wissen dass sie am Morgen vielleicht
nicht aufwachen werden
die Russen stehen nur ein paar Kilometer
entfernt trotzdem gehen die Menschen auf
den Markt verkaufen das was ihnen
geblieben ist
überall sehen wir Soldaten die sich mit
Tarnkleidung und Ausrüstung eindecken
und trotzdem bleiben vor allem die
älteren
wohin soll ich fahren wer braucht mich
mit so einer niedrigen Rente 2500
riffner wo kann ich für dieses Geld
leben wir denken dass wir siegen werden
wir haben nicht vor unsere Stadt zu
verlassen
die Straße runter stehen sie für Milch
an wir treffen Tatjana sie ist 14 wie
schwer ist es gerade in
schwer aber wir halten durch
Krieg als Normalzustand Alltag in Kopien
auch viele Menschen in der früheren
Sowjetrepublik Georgien fürchten
russische Aggressionen gerade ist
Außenministerin baerbock in Georgien die
Kaukasusrepublik mit ihren 3,7 Millionen
Einwohnern strebt zwar in die EU steht
aber im Schatten des mächtigen Nachbarn
Russland Moskau führte 2008 Krieg gegen
das kleine Land und unterstützt seitdem
die abgespaltenen Gebiete ab Asien und
südostizien die Außenministerin war auch
an der Demarkationslinie dort Andreas
Kühnast berichtet
das weiße bitte ab hier ab dem Dorf
mukani sind keine zivilen Fahrzeuge mehr
erlaubt keine Ausnahmen für Minister 20
Minuten noch bis zur sogenannten
verwaltungslinie hinter der sich gleich
der erste russische Stützpunkt
verschanzt da ist eine Wiese und in der
Wiese
die Wiese und alles da drüben ist
süd-ositien nur anerkannt von Russland
wenn er zu Wähler Nicaragua und Syrien
auch da drüben ist Georgien sagen der
Rest der Welt und Georgien ich danke der
deutschen Delegation dass sie die
territoriale Integrität unseres Landes
so unterstützt
russlandsbesetzung Russlands Einfluss
ist das Thema von bärbox Besuch das
Thema Georgiens erbittert kämpft das
Land seit Wochen um seine Zukunft auf
der Straße zehntausende die den Weg in
Richtung EU fortsetzen wollen im
Parlament die Regierung die sich mit
Händen und Fäusten gegen die dafür
nötigen Reformen Wert ein sogenanntes
agentengesetz wie in Russland hätte das
Staatsziel EU beinahe zerstört die
Ohren jetzt zur EU die Menschen die
orgiens sie gehören in die EU vertrauen
Sie nicht diese Regierung das ist die
Botschaft die diese mit Organisatorinnen
der Proteste bärburg mitgeben auf all zu
scharfe Kritik an Georgiens Regierung
hat bärburg verzichtet weil sie keine
grundsätzlichen Zweifel an ihrem eu-kurs
hat auch wenn das die Opposition hier in
tief ist völlig anders einschätzt
Deutschland sieht wie Georgien schwankt
und sicher dem Land Stabilisierung zu
eigentlich sollte der britische König
Charles ab Sonntag für drei Tage nach
Frankreich reisen doch Präsident macron
hat den Staatsbesuch verschoben wegen
der Massendemonstrationen die Proteste
gegen macrons Rentenreform werden immer
gewalttätiger bei einem landesweiten
Aktionstag gestern kam es in mehreren
Städten zu Ausschreitungen mehr als 400
Polizisten sollen verletzt worden sein
fast 460 Menschen wurden festgenommen
Wissenschaft als Beruf wer das anstrebt
dem drohen künftig wohl noch höhere
Hürden
205.000 wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter
gibt es an den deutschen Hochschulen
nach der Promotion haben sie derzeit
maximal sechs Jahre Zeit die
Voraussetzungen für eine Professur zu
erfüllen und damit für eine
Festanstellung sonst müssen sie gehen
diese Frist soll jetzt auf drei Jahre
verkürzt werden was die Betroffenen
davon halten machten sie heute vor dem
zuständigen Ministerium deutlich aus
Berlin Silvia blessmann
wütend und frustriert ist Barbara Ort
ihre Doktor wird die bei vielen anderen
nicht verlängert gemeinsam kämpfen sie
für unbefristete Verträge und faire
Beschäftigung es ist wichtig dass es
Wissenschaft hinaus bekannt wird wie
prekär wir leben wie schlecht unsere
Arbeitsbedingungen sind im Netz finden
sich viele die wie Barbara Ort unter dem
Hashtag ich bin Hanna über prekäre
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Wissenschaft
schreiben die 32-Jährige hat
internationale Beziehungen studiert und
promoviert gerade wie alle anderen hat
sie nur eine Teilzeitstelle arbeitet
dafür aber in der Regel 60 Stunden für
die Uni sagt sie der Gesetzesvorschlag
für sie ein Schock ich kann mich jetzt
entscheiden ob ich den Beruf Wechsel
oder ob ich Deutschland verlasse für
immer und das ist natürlich bitter mit
dem neuen Vorschlag der jetzt durchgehen
würde gibt es einfach keine Möglichkeit
mehr innerhalb der neuen vorgeschlagen
Befristung von drei Jahren sich soweit
zu qualifizieren dass man ein Professur
erreichen kann unbefristete Stellen gibt
es nur sehr wenige im
Wissenschaftsbetrieb das frustriert auch
Soziologe Jonas Wiedner er hat bereits
den dritten Zeitvertrag weiß nicht wie
es danach weitergeht wenn es eine
Perspektive für mich gibt dann außerhalb
der Wissenschaft oder im Ausland und was
mich stört ist dass ich sehe dass es in
anderen europäischen Ländern durchaus
funktioniert
karrierestrukturen im Vergleich zeigen
in Deutschland haben nur 27% eine
unbefristete Stelle in den Niederlanden
sind es 63 Prozent und in England sogar
74% mit einer sicheren unbefristeten
stelle sie wollen Perspektiven mehr
unbefristete Stellen längere
Vertragszeiten dafür bekommen sie viel
Unterstützung auch von verbeamteten
Professoren wie die Politik darauf
reagiert ist noch unklar
sich jedes Jahr vier Wochen Zeit nehmen
für innere Einkehr Demut Gemeinschaft
und Wohltätigkeit auch in Deutschland
praktizieren Millionen gläubige Muslime
wieder Ramadan in diesem Fastenmonat
verzichten sie von der Morgendämmerung
bis zum Sonnenuntergang unter anderem
auf Essen Trinken und Rauchen was das
bedeutet zeigt Peter Böhmer
eine lange Schlange vor einem
Bäckerladen gestern Abend in Köln noch
zehn Minuten bis Sonnenuntergang dann
dürfen sie wieder essen das Fasten
brechen mit dem Brut Heim zu ihren
Familien gehen
erste Tag ist zwar jetzt aufregend aber
man hat natürlich auch Hunger die
Anstrengung auch wenn man arbeitet Essen
ist noch nicht mal das Problem aber das
Trinken also man möchte schon gerne
trinken gegen 19 Uhr in Düsseldorf beim
Verband islamischer Kulturzentren nach
dem Gebet warten nach über 14 Stunden
Fasten Speisen und Getränke auf sie das
erste gemeinsame mal nach drei Jahren
corona-pause zusammen sein das hat
gefehlt diese Verbundenheit man hat sich
alleine gefühlt jeder war dann halt
alleine für sich selber zu Hause in den
eigenen vier Wänden das ist eine sehr
sehr schlimme Zeit für für alle Leute
gewesen der Ramadan ist ein Monat der
Besinnung Frömmigkeit und Gemeinschaft
die Gläubigen dürfen tagsüber nicht
essen und trinken ausgenommen sind
Schwangere kranke
ältere und Kinder
mein Freund natürlich auf das Essen noch
auf das Gerät auf die Familie auf das
gemeinsame ein bisschen also es ist mehr
Ramadan ist mehr als nur hungern in
diesem Jahr gehen die Gedanken vieler
Gläubiger in die türkischen und
syrischen Erdbebengebiete viele haben
dort Verwandte und Freunde verloren
bisher sind übrigens
251 Millionen Euro in Deutschland für
die Erdbeben Opfer in der Türkei und in
Syrien gespendet worden das meldet heute
das deutsche Zentralinstitut für soziale
Fragen
kein Instagram und Co mehr nach 22 Uhr
diese Regel gilt künftig für
Minderjährige im US-Bundesstaat Utah und
zwar per Gesetz die Social Media konnten
sollen demnach nachts automatisch
gesperrt werden außerdem müssen die
Plattformen Werbung einschränken und den
Eltern Zugriff ermöglichen so wolle man
die Psyche der Kinder schützen heißt es
zur Begründung weitere US-Staaten planen
ähnliches
so jetzt der sportliche Hammer des Tages
der FC Bayern hat Trainer nagelsmann
entlassen überraschend aber aus Bayern
Sicht wohl nachvollziehbar zu viel Ärger
mit und um nagelsmann zu viele
Schlagzeilen statt schlagen der Erfolge
in der Liga das Top-Team immer noch
nicht in konstanter Topform nun soll es
der neue Trainer Thomas richten
es ist ein Trainer Beben von
europäischem Ausmaß was ist kaputt
gegangen nicht nur der Glaube bei den
Verantwortlichen nach der eins zu zwei
Niederlage von München in Leverkusen
Reaktionen
sehr turbulent würde ich sagen
also die Nachricht kam sehr überraschend
was ich sagen kann ist dass
Julian möglichen ja überragender Trainer
ist eine der besten die ich je hatte
Zauberfußball zum Bundesliga Beginn 6:1
in Frankfurt in der Champions League
acht Spiele acht Siege trotzdem
bayernsvorstand vermisste zuletzt die
Qualität einer Mannschaft die in ihr
steckt und sicherlich spielt die
Entlassung von Torwarttrainer tabalovic
Freund von neuer eine Rolle jetzt
übernimmt dann Champions League Sieger
Thomas Tuchel Vertrag bis 2025 er soll
als extremer von Dortmund eben jene
Borussia wieder vom bundesligatron
stoßen und Julian nagelsmann in dieser
Saison hatte nur drei von 37 Spielen
verloren seine Abfindung wird Bayern
einen zweistelligen Millionenbetrag
kosten
ja heute dreht sich alles um die Bayern
morgen steht das DFB-Team im Rampenlicht
erstens Länderspiel des Jahres gegen
Peru und da verspricht Trainer Hansi
Flick Leidenschaft und Engagement der
Bundestrainer ließ heute offen ob einer
der sechs Neulinge in der Startelf steht
am ehesten darf BVB Außenverteidiger
Marius Wolf auf einen einsatzhaufen
sicher ist dass Hansi flieg auf eine
Doppelspitze setzen wird mit dem WM
Lichtblick Niklas Füllkrug und Timo
Werner nach fünf intensiven
Trainingstagen fordert der Chef einen
überzeugenden Auftritt wir wollen zeigen
dass die Mannschaft einfach mit sehr
viel Leidenschaft mit sehr viel
Engagement auch das Spiel angeht dass
sie mit Selbstvertrauen auch
in die Spiele reingeht und ich glaube
das sind die Dinge die jeder Fan auch
sehen möchte jeder Zuschauer aussehen
möchte das Spiel in Mainz ist
ausverkauft und ein erster Stimmungstest
nach der WM
18 Sportarten 129 deutsche Meistertitel
das sind die Finals 2023 vom 6 bis 9
juli Austragungsorte diesmal Duisburg
Düsseldorf Kassel und Berlin ZDF und ARD
sind wieder live dabei
umfangreiche Berichterstattung im
Fernsehen und in verschiedenen
Livestreams die Finals 2023 ein
Multisport Event im Sommer das in diesem
Jahr schwerpunktmäßig in der Region
Rhein-Ruhr stattfindet wir holen den
Sport hier ganz nah an die an die
Menschen ran ein bisschen eine Mischung
aus Sportfest und Volksfest die
Zuschauer vor Ort werden sowohl
traditionelle Sportarten wie Triathlon
und turnen als auch junge olympische
Sportarten wie breaking und Klettern zu
Gesicht bekommen noch rund 100 Tage bis
sich Deutschlands beste Athletinnen und
Athleten miteinander messen werden
bestimmt vier tolle Tage im Juli danke
schön morgen gibt's April Wetter mit
Gewitter und stürmischem Wind die
Details hat gleich Christa Augen um zehn
begrüßt Sie Marietta Slomka im heute
journal die gesamte heute Crew wünscht
Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend da will es doch tatsächlich
der Spätwinter noch einmal wissen die
Temperaturen sinken über das Wochenende
hier zum Beispiel in Berlin von knapp 15
auf nur noch um fünf Grad in der Nacht
auf Dienstag ist dann Frost möglich und
es besteht die Option auf Schnee heute
Nacht aber erstmal nicht da gibt es
Schauer schauerartig verstärkten Regen
auch mal ein einzelnes Gewitter und das
ist meist stark bewölkt die Nacht ist
aber noch recht mild 4 bis 8 Grad aber
schon nicht mehr so mild wie die
vergangene Nacht da hatten wir teils
Tiefstwerte von um 12 Grad also das war
wirklich mild morgen erreichen den
meistens noch zwei stellige Höchstwerte
zwischen 10 und 14 Grad nur an der
Nordsee und den Berglagen ist das etwas
weniger und dazu wird es ein Tag an dem
es überall mal alles geben kann grauen
Himmel Schauer dann Auflockerungen auch
einzelne Gewitter und das wird sich für
uns alle recht rau anfühlen denn es gibt
einen frischen bis starken südwestlichen
Wind hier in diesem gelben Flächen gibt
es verbreitet stürmische Böden in
Gewittern sind auch Stunden mit dabei in
Berglagen sogar schwere Sturmböen und
dieser ungestüme Wind weht dann die
Frühlingsluft davon am Montag nur noch
Höchstwerte zwischen zwei und acht Grad
auch die Schneeflocken kommen mit diesem
kräftigen Nordwind wieder zurück davor
am Sonntag noch vergleichsweise Milch
mit viel Regen in der Mitte und im Süden
im Norden ist das dagegen trocken
tschüss